je pense que maintenant à l'appel
sous mes pieds à
facile à un bon mètre salut brut moi
c'est thomas et ça c'est mon quotidien
ça c'est mon métier je suis nettoyeur de
l'extrême
nous on intervient là où personne ne
veut intervenir
depuis cinq ans thomas des baraques une
étoile des logements très encombré voire
insalubres et son chantier du jour c'est
cet appartement de 30 mètres carrés la
première étape ça va être la phase de
tri de préparation je vais refaire on a
pris des sacs poubelle avec nous on va
mettre tout les toutes les poubelles sa
poubelle les détritus on va faire
attention à trier le verre parce que
c'est assez lourd dans des sacs à part
des sacs jaunes et le reste dans des
gros sacs poubelles noirs qu'on va tout
donner
objectif que ce soir appartenance ville
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thomas était contacté par la
propriétaire de l'appartement à la suite
de la finition des allocataires on a
reçu des consignes particulières dire
que là on va devoir retrouver les
papiers d'identité voilà on va trouver
tout ce qui est courrier important tous
les documents administratifs les photos
personnelles également est trop tôt de
folie on constate clairement de la
personne souffrait du syndrome de
diogène
parce que là il ya une accumulation
vraiment extrême de détritus ces moments
une personne qui laissait rien sortir de
chez elle tu vois tu as eu des
difficultés pour ouvrir la porte parce
qu'en fait les déchets ils sont tombés
d'un rapporte ici un départ d'incendié
c'est vraiment catastrophique
le syndrome de diogène est un trouble du
comportement qui conduit à l'église et
son hygiène corporelle et lycées donc là
on à 2019 donc le paquet déjà hyper
immer 2019 on pouvait plus voilà donc
déjà on sait déjà que ça fait au moins
deux ans qui est comme ça en tout cas
que ce papier la
nouvelle 2017
ouais
ouais c'est pas forcément typique mais
ça arrive très fréquemment en général
les toilettes sont complets à frédéric
robin passe quelque part c'est dans le
sachet c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
retrouve des bouteilles
on n'est pas du tout dans le jugement
donc c'est bon ça faut pas hésiter à
venir nous parler même si c'est
difficile on le sait pour eux parce
qu'ils sont comme ici zones socialement
donc ils veulent pas du tout partagé
montrer leur logement mais voilà ils
savent qu'avec nouvelles peuvent
s'ouvrir
bouge vraiment des rats ce genre de
choses les poubelles au début c'était un
peu choquant mais maintenant c'est
devenu une habitude je pense que pas
tout le monde justement aimerait faire
ce métier comme juste toujours il faut
bien que quelqu'un le fasse et on est là
justement pour pour aider les personnes
qui sont dans le besoin
d'une certaine façon je pense que oui
sinon je ne serais pas là ça c'est sur
la terre ce qui est terrible c'est les
puces et les punaises de lit voilà parce
que c'est extrêmement petit séjour à
anéantir à dire mais il ya un gros
risque d'infection là on peut en
attraper et les ramener après chez nous
dans nos véhicules dans les maisons et
ça c'est pour ça qu'on prend des
précautions mais des combinaisons
quand il ya des motifs de nuisibles là
on va vous mettre du scotch carrément au
poignet et au niveau des chevilles pour
qu'on puisse avoir une combinaison
totalement hermétique effectif jamais eu
de problème donc
c'est du bon partout
quand on rend les clés combat du client
souvent ils sont en pleurs parce qu'ils
y pensent que c'était impossible et
c'est ça qui est très satisfaisant
on arrive à changer la vie justement de
certaines personnes qui souffrent du
syndrome de diogène on en a aidé
quelques années et qui maintenant veut
totalement
normalement et nous envoient des photos
régulièrement de leur logement en ville
avec un ca vous m'avez sortir d'une
mauvaise passe et je suis passé à autre
chose on a en tout cas l'impression de
faire un métier qui est critique
[Musique]
j'allais après deux jours de travail
intensif le travail est enfin terminée
on a débarrassé donc plus de trois
tonnes de détritus effectuer un
nettoyage désinfection
voilà c'était deux jours de travail très
intense et c'est notre quotidien